from healthcare to education to
advertising data is helping businesses
innovate to new heights
a key challenge is not just how to find
data but how to make it useful
data scientists and data engineers often
need to build data pipelines to ingest
process and analyze their data
these etl and elt type workflows usually
involve multiple services that need to
be coordinated and executed at the right
time and under the right conditions
in our previous video we learned about
how orchestration is the automation
management and coordination of workflows
in this video we'll focus on how you can
orchestrate your data workflows in
google cloud using cloud composer this
is where cloud composer google cloud's
fully managed orchestration service
comes into play
you can use composer to create schedule
and monitor and end workflows using
python
composer is built on the open source
apache airflow project which has a huge
community of contributors and users
and since it's a fully managed service
you don't have to worry about managing
airflow deployments
composer takes care of infrastructure
management for you so you can focus on
actually building your data pipelines
composer supports many different use
cases but most of its users are data
engineers who are building workflows to
orchestrate their data pipelines
there are several key advantages that
composer has for the data workflows use
case
first the airflow project has hundreds
of operators and sensors you can use
these make it easy to communicate across
multiple cloud environments with very
little code
in addition to google cloud operators
there are multiple operators for other
common interfaces like mysql and slack
second composer has sophisticated task
management
you can parallelize and branch tasks and
define how you want to handle failure
for example you could send out an email
to the team if something goes wrong
along the way
and third keeping track of your
workflows is straightforward with
composer's built-in monitoring all of
this is important as your workflows
scale and become more complex
and finally composer comes with
enterprise ready security features like
customer managed encryption keys and vpc
service control support
enabling organizations to use it right
away without worrying about security
compliance
it's important to note that composer is
not designed to transform process or
pass along large amounts of data
instead composer is great for managing
and coordinating tasks delegated to
other products that handle your data
some products you might want to
coordinate using composer include
bigquery data flow data proc and data
fusion
these are all great at operating
directly on big data
let's take a look at an example use case
about composer can be used to
orchestrate a big data pipeline
composer tasks are defined in the form
of a python directed acyclic graph or
dag
first we monitor a cloud storage bucket
and trigger the pipeline as soon as the
file appears
then we kick off a cloud dataflow
pipeline
next we execute a bigquery sql job to
validate the process data
and finally we delete the object from
the cloud storage bucket since we no
longer need it
along the way if anything goes wrong a
slack notification can be sent to team
members
and there you have it
data orchestration is becoming
increasingly important for data
engineers and developers to manage their
tasks and services
by having composer orchestrate workflows
on their behalf data engineers can focus
their efforts on the more creative
aspects of data engineering
make sure to check out the next video in
our series where we'll learn more about
how to build workflows in cloud composer